Phase two induced with setting up
IPsec SA which is a one way association.
But multiple IPsec SA's
can be negotiated with
the protection of the same
IKE SA established in phase one.
The phase two protocol looks very
similar to the phase one protocol.
The difference is in how
the IPSec keys are derived.
If there's no perfect
forward secrecy is required,
then these keys can be derived
from one of the shared keys,
specifically the SKID-T
computed in phase one.
The weakness is that,
if that key is somehow leaked,
then all the IPSec SA
keys are also leaked.
Stronger security requires
perfect forward secrecy.
In this case,
both sides exchange new nonce values and
perform new Diffie-Hellman key exchange.
With perfect forward secrecy,
each time an IPSec SA is negotiated,
its keys are created using
the pre-shared key, and
the new information that
has been exchanged.
Such as, the new nounce values and
the new pubic components of
the [INAUDIBLE] key change.
Therefore, unless the pre-shared key
which can be considered as the master
share secure key is compromised.
The keys for
the current IPsec SA are secure,
even if other keys previously
computed have been compromised.